before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
spies fascist and data collection oh my
thank you
[Music]
spy fall part two the conclusion of the
first two-part story of the Jody
Whitaker era and
I wasn't really sure what I was going to
get out of this it's actually that's
kind of where I'm at with a lot of
series 12 because my overall takeaway
impression of series 12 was this is
definitely better than series 11 for the
most part up until the finale but let's
not get ahead of ourselves
but I didn't know going back and
revisiting it how much of it was going
to be is that because it was genuinely
strong material was it just a little bit
better or was it just capturing a feel
that I wanted more that I was
overlooking some problems
and in the case of this part two at
least it's at least a little bit of that
last thing because watching this now
without the thrill of getting to see
Sasha Dewan really own as the master
because I like him a lot as the master
without that really hitting for the
first time being like oh this is so
exciting and actually examining it more
as an actual piece of fiction as a as a
narrative it's it's a it's it you know
what it is it's overstuffed which is
going to be a bit of a recurring issue
for chip Knoll especially going forward
which is odd because series 11 I don't
think you could really accuse it being
overstuffed maybe maybe you could accuse
Battle of rent score I have colos being
overstuffed insofar as there were a lot
of ideas in there that should have been
expanded on and could have been the bulk
of the episode things like the psychic
Planet which ultimately meant nothing so
these ideas just kind of get thrown away
but it it felt that felt more
undercooked than overstuffed
here there's frankly too much going on
and things don't pay off properly
because they're kind of stepping on each
other's toes basically what that mostly
boils down to is that the master kind of
just devours the rest of the story
because we've still got all this
holdover stuff from Barton The Tech Guy
and with this new species that we're now
dealing with and it taking out spies and
it's it's all over the planet all this
stuff going on with there and that's
technically still present and it does
from a strictly check box uh sort of
thing does get wrapped up but it feels
like it's wrapped up as a side note
because we've got the master now so
we're going to focus the master front
and center and include this entire let's
have the master and the doctor encounter
each other across multiple points in
history which is fun don't get me wrong
in isolation with those scenes but those
scenes aren't an active part of the
narrative that have been going on up to
this point so they take away from the
time that is available to actually tell
the story that the first one was
and actually deal with all that
the master wasn't intrusive in part one
because we didn't even know he was there
until the very end here he's here from
the beginning and while I love all of
his scenes
it really does feel like he has just
taken over and robbed the other stories
of feeling like they are properly dealt
with which is part of why this feels
particularly overloaded with
technobabble if I use my stomach on the
silver lady I might be able to force
this creature to turn me back to the
21st century I mean technobabble is
something that can affect any era of
Doctor Who to be completely honest but
in this particular case
in order to tie together and explain all
the things like what the Master's plan
even is how the doctor keeps running
into him him like teaming up with uh the
Nazis and not being called out by them
I'm going to come back to that whole
scene but we got to deal with that the
doctor runs into Ada and then you know
jumps ahead and runs into Nora why is
that happening why is Ada connected with
this species what are the cassavin even
trying to accomplish why is Barton
working with them why does he think it's
a good idea all these things kind of
sort of get touched on but because a lot
of them have complicated answers
particularly what the cassavan are where
they come from what they're trying to
accomplish what Barton is hoping to get
out of this
do you explain those things in the cut
down amount of time because of how much
time is just eaten up by Sasha Dewan
means that we just get techno Babble
dumps the doctor just says a bunch of
nonsense Tech sounding terms that are
meant to explain why that's a thing
where honestly the much cleaner thing
would have been to simplify it and take
some of these things out like I don't
dislike the stuff with Ada or the stuff
with nor
but it's not adding anything and having
it there is removing the ability of this
other stuff to be able to move forward
in a way that doesn't feel rushed and
ham-fisted so that's that's sort of the
overstuffed problem that's going on with
this episode but that's a that's the
massive structural issue again though I
really do like Sasha dewan's Master like
a lot and I really I love there's a lot
of subtlety in both his performance and
Whitaker's performance when he has her
Neo and he tells her to call him by his
name she initially she just has this
exhausted it's it's a borderline eye
roll this
Musta like she can't believe she's
saying this and then you know meets his
eyes when he's like what sorry what was
that so like him pulling it out of her
and the look in her eyes when she meets
his gaze oh there's a lot going on in
there and that interaction and it plays
really really well in many ways this
kind of feels like an amalgamation of
stuff that's worked elsewhere you know
the the reveal of the master from
someone we thought was an ally that's
pulled from Utopia the master you know
having this whole bring the doctor down
to their knees that's very much the uh
sound of drums trial of a Time Lord the
visual language of the cassavan is very
Army of Ghosts the mass adoption of a
piece of technology to take over the
world is very um age of Steel the
resolution of the plane is very blank
and I don't want to have that sound too
dismissive because despite the
overstuffed issue which I brought up but
like these aren't bad elements to pull
from and there's honestly there's
nothing wrong with reusing them Doctor
Who has been around for almost 60 years
now it's totally okay to repurpose some
ideas that's fine but I'm not sure how
much more is going on other than the
repurposing because like the the stuff
the other stuff that's here again just
feels very brushed we have the
technobabble explanations and then with
Barton we have this weird scene with him
and his mother that feels like honestly
a motivation equivalent of a
technobabble scene whereas the Techno
Babel scenes are used to explain why the
doctors jumping through time or didn't
make it all the way to the present or
whatever and we just dropped some techno
Babble here we have Barton have this
confrontation with his mother
because I guess they feel like just a
man wanting to be in control of the
world isn't enough motivation
so we have to give him mother issues in
this one scene where it really doesn't
feel like it's a proper culmination of
anything or even a deep explanation it's
just like oh okay so yeah issues got it
that didn't really add anything I mean
like it might have if there have been
more time to bring Barton forward and
have him be the primary villain of the
entire two-parter instead of just the
first one and actually delved into him a
bit more as a character but again we
don't have time we've got the master now
so okay we need to talk about the the
Nazi scene
um because this is something that I
didn't pick up on the thing that a lot
of people ended up having issue with
um later
um because you know back when I first
saw it because I don't watch other
people's reviews and it didn't occur to
me at the time so there is some
um concern
about how it reflects on this particular
doctor's moral compass that in the
process of defeating him she removed
because it gets pointed out like you're
not exactly an Aryan poster child and he
says you know I'm using a perception
filter they see what they think they
should see when they look at this
uniform and she disables that perception
filter and leaves him to the Nazis
you good luck
which means she's sort of
weaponized racial hatred
against somebody and even somebody like
the master that is a bit
okay here's the thing that makes it
weirder for me
she didn't have to do that
because she'd already cooked his Goose
because she did this whole thing with
um sending a message that she knew the
Germans would intercept implicating him
and be like thanks so much for all the
for all the spying you've been doing for
us over here in the UK
telling them how valuable you've been as
a double agent she'd already uh removed
his ability to just hide there she'd
already cooked his Goose so the entire
removal of the perception filter is
completely unnecessary
that's honestly what makes it weirder to
me it would already be a weird decision
if that was the thing that she did to
get the Nazis to turn on him
but the fact that she'd already turned
them against him
and still did that too that makes it
real weird
I don't think there's a lot of specific
malicious intent behind that I think
there is a lack of thought
I think that this was an idea that was
had and the implications of what this
says about what this doctor is willing
to do what line she's willing to cross
what kinds of evil she's willing to
weaponize I don't think those things
were thought through not that the doctor
has ever been above weaponizing evil
against another foe that is definitely
something that has happened a number of
times but something about it being
genocidal racial hatred and real life
genocidal racial hatred in particular
it's just feels really inappropriate
um
and I don't know there's something about
the master that didn't honestly even
before that part didn't quite feel right
him in that uniform
because that's not Who the Master is
the Master's power hungry the master is
opportunistic the master is scheming
he's not genocidal
not as an end to itself he has no
problem wiping on entire species at all
but like that's not his deal
and Doctor Who already has direct
comparisons to the Nazis with the Daleks
if you wanted to have somebody
infiltrating the Nazis davros is much
better pick for that than the master is
at the same time like the Master's not
above this it's not like he's too good
for this if he thinks that this will
give him an advantage so I'm not going
to say it's out of character
it just feels like
they're trying to associate him with a
real world evil that doesn't map right
onto him especially given that there are
other villains in Doctor Who that it
does map onto
again the actual scene when we have the
interactions between the master and the
doctor in that portion are really good
the master and the amount of just kind
of knife twisting he's trying to do to
her and and little things like him
asking did I ever apologize for that
oh
good you get that sense that they used
to be friends which is something I like
in a master doctor scene and the best
ones have that that and so like their
interactions are still really good but I
kind of suspect a lot of that is down to
the performance because when I think
about the actual construction of the
scene I kind of tilt my head a little
bit at some of this and I think you know
what it's not just that the master kind
of takes over the story it's that what
he's doing doesn't mesh and flow with
what the cassavan and what Barton are
doing
either logistically or thematically and
it's like the logistical not all meshing
together is fine he's using them for his
own purposes that's a thing he does but
there was a really strong thematic core
when you were looking at Barton and the
cassavan because the cassavan honestly
kind of had a cold war thing going for
them this implanting of spies everywhere
we put people everywhere and we listen
and we watch and we gather information
and sort of mirroring that with data
collection through technology like
Barton's doing through Vore I still
can't believe they used that without
Googling what the heck that means those
two things mesh thematically very well
old school spycraft modern era data
collection
the master is just here to mess with the
doctor basically like technically his
plan is not just that but that is what
he's focused on that's what he's
spending almost his entire time here
doing
so I think that's part of the reason why
it feels like he's pulling away from the
other
um villains because what he's doing
doesn't match what they're doing and so
we're losing a very relevant theme of
villainy over here so that we can focus
on the master
I I feel like
the better call would have been to
reveal the master maybe towards the end
of the second part of this so that the
time could be properly devoted to
wrapping up the actual plot that most of
the rest of it was and then we do an
episode after this dedicated to the
master and give him a full Spotlight so
he's not just pulling Focus from other
things which is kind of what we end up
with there's some other things uh both
good and good and bad I like I kind of
like that the doctor is all disapproving
of ADA as Ada gets you know uh this
machine gun and then a and then a
grenade and the doctor's like I do not
approve but you know what this is
helpful so she's going to do it anyway
so that was that was a fun to that that
I enjoyed there was a weird moment of
interaction between Ryan and Graham was
right
we carry on doing what the dog would
want us to do sorry did you just say
Ryan's right yes I did enjoy the moment
son maybe it's been too long since I did
my re-watch in series 11 but I don't
remember Graham assuming Ryan was wrong
about everything being a running thing
maybe my memory is just failing at me it
felt like an odd thing to highlight we
get our first proper drop and uh really
reference to the importance of the
Timeless child which was a term actually
heard in the previous series but it gets
emphasis here and it's the LIE of the
Timeless child and stick a pin in this
because I'm gonna have to come back to
it eventually I'm still trying to
struggle as to why this matters so much
to the master
I'm you know and I don't love that
Gallifrey got destroyed again like could
we can we pick something and just leave
it all especially because so little ever
happens at Gallifrey especially in the
modern era it's not like we do entire
story set there either have it be safe
somewhere off where it's not gonna
bother the the rest of the story or have
it stay destroyed but this whole is
destroyed it's back it's safe but it's
in a separate bubble Universe I found it
and I destroyed it I'm like for God's
sake this thing's like a kickball it's
just getting knocked back and forth
between these states of it's fine and
it's destroyed I'm like I have no
investment in this at this point
and like gypnol I would say did not even
try like he's banking on a pre-existing
investment in Gallifrey when it's a
setting he hasn't done anything with
uh I don't know that that we're gonna
deal a lot more with that later on
anyways I do kind of like that the
doctor kind of has her clamming up
um at the end of this when the
companions are like hey do you want to
talk to us about what we just went
through and the doctor's like no and
then then she gives an answer but it's a
very bullet point answer like okay well
here's the thing here's what's going on
here's the master here's the deal any
other questions it's very off-putting
and now knowing how much of a actual
intended part of the character that is
that she is very bad at relating
especially emotionally
um when something is Weighing on her I
yeah I think that's pretty well handled
one could argue it's sort of clucky and
clunky and like checking boxes but it
makes sense to me because it's she's
treating answering these questions not
as a way to unburden herself emotionally
but going through a checklist of okay
here's the things you need to know can
we be done
and I think that fits for how she's
being characterized at this point
but yeah it's it's a bit of a letdown
from part one unfortunately but that's
spy fall part two have you rewatched it
lately what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon is what pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living any amount you can support me
there is of great assistance even if you
can't though like share subscribe also
help me out but don't worry too much
about that either
because what I really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
end of the video so I gotta shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin mcfula
Tarak the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjornison Melinda
Walters kimudelki the oatha Boyd katoria
toy lowly Becky Sparks for navilax the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Jayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what you doing there
[Music]